all right
oh
structure
i guess i didn't really have anything
specifically prepared but as i i have uh
i guess
the overall
topic i thought that would be
interesting to discuss would be what and
what would it mean for us to
design
our algorithms that optimally
efficiently exploit structure that arise
and i i do feel like the
like it matters a lot in order for it to
be
useful to
practice and
applications
i feel like it would be
important to pick what kind of structure
and understand what kind of structure
is actually significant that if we
were as a community to
be able to figure out and solve like how
do we
you know if
uh design our algorithms have to
officially split that structure um
um
like that could actually translate to
something useful in practice because a
lot of interesting applications
so i guess maybe one question would be
what our
um
applications or um
that we could kind of
uh brainstorms that have some kind of
structure where we can spend a bit of
time to think about
what is the relevant structure and how
do you formulate that structure uh in
um some you know notation that means
something's happy feast so
i guess applications that uh
[Music]
so i guess here i was thinking more just
um i feel like we do need a bag of
applications that to start with to
motivate what kinds of structure
um are significant and i guess so
maybe the second question then would be
what are the types of
structures
that arise
and maybe
uh
here maybe are there any significant
connections being algorithms
and what are the open problems um
and i think uh in this case there's also
um anomaly existing algorithms maybe we
want to understand an existing
whether it's possible to get more
instance
independent lower bounds
as well uh
because i i are not just interested but
maybe like class
self class
or sub classes
[Music]
i feel what i understand so i think i
feel like this has there's been a lot of
really interesting developments in um
linear function approximation that that
that i feel i find very inspiring and
i'm wondering whether we can do that for
other
other classes of mdps to really
understand
both the hardness of exploiting that
structure
uh and what ethanol arguments would look
like and so um
if uh people
i if people want to take up something i
have been thinking about a particular
type of low rate structure that i'd be
happy to hear people's feedback on but i
also want to just open it up
i think you should start that okay
so
i guess maybe one kind of uh structure
that i've thought about a little bit is
kind of low rate and here i think i'm
actually been thinking about a very um
uh slightly different
well it's it's uh it's actually a little
bit more restrictive than
um just assuming um
the linearity
in terms of the linear uh like the
typical
formulation for linear enthalpies in
particular here
i'm looking for example
um
one assumption would be
that there is some
let's say
here
uh
low dimensional representation
um
of
the
speakers i'm sorry
of the states in action
um such that the optimal um
the optimal
key function of the key function for
actual policy
is lowering protected this speaker of
location so if i was in a tabular
setting
such in the tabular setting that's phi
and it just means that i can
factor
my um
my q function
of the optimal policy
to
something that's let's say
actually maybe i'll use oxygen
alternately
so i would say maybe the one
and the distinction i want to make
between this
model is that um
uh in the linear mvp setting um
there's the assumption on linear force
the transition so okay i should
say there's
actually let me put down the second
assumption
for the second assumption
i'm going to say slow rank
on the
transition cancer
so here
you can think of your tensor or your
transition
kernel as a tensor and look at the um
the tucker rink so think of i i take my
tensor and i can flatten it in three
different ways
so i can flatten it along
the three along each of the three modes
and look for what's the dimension of the
what of the column space
and the dimension of the column space
will be the um corresponding kind of
ranks along each of these three modes
and if these these dimensions of column
space um
of this tensor along each of these three
um along each of these three unfoldings
are kind of small
uh then this is low rank and this is a
low fiber ring or this tensor has no
factor rings
um so
this i think maybe this one might be
easier to see
um
it uh so in particular the
the corresponding features
here that would you can think of it as a
you would probably have a fee
that's maybe a few prime
um
okay
so again
where this would be
are one dimensional
and so will be our two dimensionals this
is
our three dimensional if you have a
structure like this
it means that you
can it means that you can write your
tensor
uh
like
this
this way
where
i can um
write it in a decomposition where
um there's a core tensor this is a core
temperature which is r1 by r2 by r3
and each of these are the latent factor
matrices
that would be something like
s by r1 would be s by
r2
a by
r u
um and so it's a this is a little bit
more restrictive of a linearity
structure
compared to
like the
assumption that my
um
my transition kernel
looks like
i guess something like bfs environment
say
i'm not sure if this so
uh i think this is kind of a assumption
that's um familiar and for linear mvps
and i think you know having low um
tensor attacker rank in all three modes
uh
additionally means that this
representation of the state action the
joint state actions and this part also
um factorizes and this is learning
itself
so i've been thinking about um
this type of structure where these are
unknown fee and size are all unknown but
you have a guarantee that this range
that does not grow with the same
function and so if we take for example a
tubular mvp case
then maybe you have a charity model
start with something really simple
then you have the loading q star
assumption
and you would want the center complexity
not to depend on s times a
but it to depend on s plus a
times r or something like that yeah so
ideally so that's that's a trade off so
you you kind of want to go from
something that looks like that's type a
to r times s plus a yeah is the um is
what like the goal is i think in terms
of what you would hope for
um and i think
uh well i got interested in the space
because i've worked on matrix estimation
before and you know you can show if i uh
in
like in classical setting where if i
just have some matrix it's way
um kind of get samples from the matrix
and you can um show that indeed the
number of samples that i need is really
it's pretty tight up to prior times
that's today maybe some log
don't you need those some
extra conditions
um so uh and there's a couple of extra
conditions you need
so
maybe i'll say
what's uh maybe classical
matrix estimation
uh here you have some matrix m
um think of
like
maybe so maybe i'll i'll do it maybe
my observation of them is
the expected value
plus some
independent
and
let's say
each entry
is observed independently
with probability p
this uh this is an easy problem and
furthermore you actually need one more
position
one more condition is that this
matrix
so usually the conditions
like this
i'm not going to define it too
previously but there's additional
composition called incoherence and i
think
a coherence here is some um
i guess informally speaking
means that
you can't your i guess signal
can't
be too concentrated
on a
small
subset
hot
batteries so uh
this condition is to say because i'm
sampling each entry independent with
probability p
um
um there's some randomness in my
sampling size sample so if my signal is
too concentrated on a small subset and i
just don't see that subset then i'm
going to be um you know trouble and so
this incoherence kind of
means that you
the signals kind of spread everywhere
in a nice way so that when you have
random sampling you get to see all the
say don't need to recover so i think
there's a lot of so obviously many of
these pieces are completely violated in
the url there's no um independence so
okay so let me actually map it to that
here so maybe what you would uh what you
might want is some notion that
uh
add some like maybe
um
let's say i have some just even think of
like that i have some
well
so uh i have some i want to estimate the
q function for some policy pipe
um
and
uh
but i do know what i really want is
q star right um
and one for first of all the location of
where my samples are observed it's
definitely um
it's
not going to be uh it may not be
independent depending on the policy you
choose because um
because you don't well okay so here i
think is
one this part of it where you're
sampling observations independently from
wp
um
uh
i think
uh we'll
in rl you'd have to ask like what is
your um
do you have a generated model where you
can actually choose where you're
sampling if you have a general model you
can choose where you're sampling you
could implement something like this
um if you don't then you have to deal
with the fact that your samples are very
potentially very non-uniform especially
it could be concentrated on a few states
and and there's a question of you know
what what does that mean to the lower
right you follow if some of the
structure is in the same visit
um this this this noise part is also an
issue because here my estimate i have
some q hat
um
estimate at a particular location
and if you have like how much does cube
have d being from
uh
the thing i want to estimate first of
all it's definitely not unbiased so it's
not mean zero definitely not mean zero
um
and this part of it the fact is actually
also not um
uh
it's heterosexual in that
the variance is very different across
entries and even in that case it's in
the classical settings it's kind of
difficult to efficiently figure out
estimation and just look at that
settings
and in coherence it also feels really
weird because if i have an optimal
function optimal
value function
it feels like it could be a setting
where it's like
some kind of sparse setting where
certain few of the states contain all
the reward and a few actions
so you really shouldn't expect anything
like this right
um so i think
i think that's the biggest problem this
is a very big problem and i think i i
think um
there are some reasons why this is the
type of assumption looked at in matrix
estimation and it's because uh the goal
in matrix activation often times the
same the goal might be something like
i want to minimize m hat
the expected value of them
and i want to have some let's say
minimize something like let's say the
mean squared error right so that would
be like this one
and
um
if i want to have estimate something
like this which minimize something like
the global error then i i do want this
notion that i want to recover the entire
matrix
but in all that's not my goal right my
goal i mean this is not my goal my goal
is not to recover the whole piece of
[ __ ] i really just care about did i
estimate the region of um
of the matrix that is relevant to my
optimal policy law and so i think
there is an interaction between um the
objective and the kind of condition so
disappearance comes specifically out of
that objective
um
there is some work on like if i wanted
to instead minimize i'm waiting for
venus norm um you would end up you can
relax you get a weighted version of you
know incoherence or a weighted version
of um like sampling conditions
um
but i uh
i think
well i thought well so let me tell you
about an algorithm that has been
proposed
um for
this setting
um
and um
i guess uh something i think is
interesting
um about it
it's a very simple algorithm um
i guess so this is
is
i'm going to give the tabular version of
the algorithm
oh actually
i should mention
their their algorithm is uh
infinite horizon discounted
uh generative model
um
you start
they with have some
continuous
state and action space
plus
shifts
they also have
this condition i think i'm not going to
really look at the
discontinuous part of it but uh there's
an extension to continuously this
and what the algorithm looks like
is
it
kind of
samples um
it samples it chooses a subset of rows
and a subset of columns
uh think of this as your connection so
they have a set of anchor states and
instead of anchor actions and and for
the set of anchor states
uh they sample every single action and
then for the set um and then for all
other states they sample all the anchor
actions
um
so the the sampling pattern looks like
this uh i should mention that this kind
of sampling pattern also
um
does really well and has nice properties
for classical matrix
um how are you getting samples from
qstart
oh sample is from um
uh this is not um
uh i should they're not sampling from
qsr thank you
they're sampling
the um
transition like all the cakes so they
look like
it's fair
sort of
kind of iterating
[Music]
reward
one
so it's uh they're they're they're using
the samples to construct
this part of it so
they only use this to construct the
estimate for when i say samples i
shouldn't have
a bad way to say
okay so let me do this
for each
for
each state and action
in this special states that's the
function
and i'll draw a picture
sure
so um for each uh one of these uh states
and action pairs in this
special set i'm following by coloring
here
they um sample n points from the
transition kernel use those endpoints to
to estimate this
empirical
expected or to estimate estimate
expectation but they're iterating on
their
estimate of the previous value but
actually discounted so they should be
like this
this is nothing yes
okay so you're kind of building like a
sparse model and then uh so they're only
estimating this for this these points
here
and then they estimate
let's say
for all
for all other
states and actions then the way those
states and actions are
sampled are estimated is
so
if i'm at this state
in this action
there's this special
corner where everything is sampled
i'm going to call
this part
i guess q sharp
and then there's a
these parts are also sampled
i'm going to call it this
i guess
x
this one is
and the um
the estimate for q hat looks like
looks like this
where this part is the pseudo inverse
of q's of q sharp
this one is a vector x this one is
vector y
and i know it looks really weird
but uh the easy way to explain it is for
rank one
rank one
and i should say this is
this is the r by four
we choose um
our special states in our special
actions
and even for rank one so
uh rank one
this looks like
q hat equals
that's a
equals q hat
yes
uh
the um
this pseudo inverse is just means that
you're dividing by the corner points
and these two points are these two
x and the y and you can see that if it's
rank one right this would have the
latent factor for x times the length
factor for a sharp times the electron
factor for a sharp and the leading
factor for a and the bottom is the
limiting factor that sharp times the
leading factor of any sharp so these two
cancel out and you get you know the hope
is that you want this to
approximately approximately be what you
want
if these were actually true samples from
the lowering matrix you know this will
be exact
but the reason why they use this
particular estimator is that they can
construct
uh they can construct air bounds for
this one
versus a lot of the tools
in classical making the summation it's
actually very hard to get entry white
sounds versus you can get extra
entry-wise maps for a very explicit
estimator like this one
um okay
and so
what sorry this is a long-winded summary
of
to say that
um
um
well uh what's interesting is how they
um
they prove uh they show
and they show example complexity that
looks like
uh
you know r times
s plus a
over epsilon squared which is what you
what you
think you should get right the one thing
that's kind of uh
kind of hidden an assumption somewhere
is that
this is for
uh gamma less than
like fixed constant
so think of this being like i don't know
less than
4.4 or something i don't know so it's
it's for gamma being
something small
it and and it it does not actually the
reason why it doesn't actually um
analysis does not extend
to uh
longer horizons
and
it is because
when you do the analysis of how the
errors um the errors propagate
um
there's a this quadratic form
makes the
uh
the bias blow up in a weird in
so the way that they have to
um clamp it down is to say that well
my
my gamma is
small enough to offset
the
the amplification like the the bound and
the error here
so that i still get a contraction
um but if gamma is not small enough
then i don't get a contraction when i do
this
and uh and then you know you don't have
the resulting one
and um the interesting thing is we
actually did construct
an example of a setting where
q star is not right q star is low rank
but the transition um kernel is not low
rank and just apply their algorithm
for a finite heart in the setting and
and it does slow up exponentially the
error the error in this estimate so in
particular if you want to track q star
minus q hat
and i just mentioned this v
at every point is the
max for all action
that you have
so um
i think yeah so it is interesting that
uh
it
um
empirically it actually really does
uh it can
actually blow up
exponentially in the horizon length um
this is an obvious question but
how do you take those priorities
here um how they take it and so they
suggest so first of all they're related
to me to this question of like where you
expect the sample to be yeah
they pick it um
um
spaced out because they have ships they
have a licious condition and so the main
thing they want their
uh choice of states and uh or states and
actions to kind of be spread out so that
you're you're trying to get as diverse a
set as possible and then you use them to
kind of interpret yeah so i mean i
didn't say they have so i i explained
this in the tabular setting they
actually talked about it in the
continuous directions to be spending but
it's um i mean there's an additional
piece that's really interesting about
their algorithm where they do a
discretization like they just have the
space to tap their settings do this and
then extrapolate out again and as you
run it you make the discretization grid
finer and finer
um
and so then they can you can use it to
show guarantees um
that are not just for the tubular kids
it would be just uniform random choice
yeah yeah it's trying to get
functionality yeah for traveling case
you should just do uniform random um but
like and your hope i think you would
probably need some condition
um like there needs to be some
conditioning like this that if you
sample uniformly rather than that you
take a set of rows that spans the space
and the set of columns that stands
basically
so in particular they do have a
condition that's
their choice of rows and columns like
this this matrix here has to be rank r
it has to be foreign otherwise this is
normal i mean it is a pseudonym
oh uh well this is only because then the
game continues the action space
so
think of your season actually being
embedded in the metric space and then
it's the
q star function
but in the tabular setting and
yeah
um
i think that
so some things i have
uh
i guess i made a small comment about
what we've kind of played around with
this model a little bit and have some
preliminary results but a lot of
questions i think um
so
uh
i think
so maybe the first comment is that
if you assume
um
low rank transitions
uh in terms of this particular form of
lowly transitions
done
uh their algorithm so
i'll get them from
child
it does get um
it does get a sample complexity of
y
so um
so if you like this distinction of
imposing lowering
on the transition sensor not just q star
is important
uh
and so actually yeah i should have
commented that is any direct paper or
no this is something that my student
my students are all right and we have
really never been we don't have a folks
in any way but uh we kind of
did a calculation
it's not in their paper but um this is
something that and then you don't need
this extra condition on the cube
uh the corner being full rank uh you do
still need so you still need the only
thing
only thing you you still need on for
and it's because of the estimator still
this one
and if it's uh the weight i mean the
rank uh like i guess the reason why
um
you need it is to um
argue that when you compute this
quantity
um
it's maybe maybe one way to explain what
happens if it's not true what happens if
it's not true if this if these columns
don't span this the the column space and
these rows don't span the row space is
that the
uh component of the column or world
space that's orthogonal to when it
stands you're not able to estimate
uh the effect of that right component
and so then you are um
um
uh yeah so
i guess it would show up as a bias term
um
and if you want to actually make that go
to zero you would probably have to argue
that maybe
over time
when you generate this many times that
that bias that you accumulate from um
from possibly some like sometimes you
don't have full rank it was pair of bias
in that time but the
when you sum that bias up over
the iterations it doesn't happen too
often so that um
you can still convert to an absolute
policy
um
yeah so right now this one is this is a
weird condition i completely agree yeah
i wonder whether that would actually
impact
center complexity
um so that this
very nice r plus r times s plus a would
be ruined and maybe we're back to s time
say
right
um i mean i think that that probably
the natural freaks if you just sample
our prime and the mean they may think
that you want
like you want to sample a large enough
set of verbal
yes um
and then you would get dependence on our
kind there instead
um
uh if you're in a case when it's like
really sparse
there's only like this special world
that
is completely orthogonal to all the
other roads
you would probably be in trouble
yeah
this is not possible yeah so i would be
very interested in the lower bound um i
think one thing that is a question to me
is that
although like there's really interesting
and nice lower bounds for the linear mdp
setting but if i look at them even
though they show exponential in in the
like in the dimension like here um it's
exponential and are but linear in the
size of the same action space right so
uh at the end of the day the all the
lower bounds even for linear mdps
wouldn't be able to
say something meaningful by the
synthetic because we really really want
to
ask when can when
does the lower bound is something that's
larger than s plus a
um
and
i mean i think there's a lot of strong
things about these models like you need
a journal model it's a very weird this
is a very weird sampling pattern like as
in you know
can you design a low regret algorithm um
i don't know
um you can't do the charity of studying
this
it may be even harder to do yeah if you
don't have narrative then like we don't
have any idea
also even
even um
one thing that's slightly more relaxed
would be suppose you don't have a
generative article but you have a
uniform sampling article
um
where i mean
so it feels like maybe uniform exactly
oracle might be powerful enough because
like major destination all you need is
like uniform samples it's i'm not sure
if that's really but my understanding is
that even for the charity case the
question is not resolved
because there is this weird condition
there's a yeah this weird yeah this
condition yeah that's true
that's just not
really the result that one is hoping for
yes yes yeah and
like uniform sampling would it give you
much because i could just pad a bunch of
states zero value
yeah that's true you would only see
those most of the time
it's still low rank it's just zeros
oh okay yeah so you're right so i guess
you're right because uh this incoherence
and the uniform sampling really interact
with each other and that if you have
something like being coherent it means
that your signal is spread everywhere
um then that's why that's kind of what
motivates you to harm sampling because
it means you're sampling from you're
getting all the signals like if you
um if your signal was concentrated on
like one rule or column you'd have to
somehow guarantee that you sampled that
one right and which would not be uniform
you're right
um
but uh that would be the challenge of i
mean that is the challenge of our
already exploration and uh
and
yeah um
i think
we um
also
like
in this preliminary work with the
students um we also showed uh i guess
two more
like uh
it's also i guess another algorithm
this other algorithm is is kind of
uh oh i can't mention
but this other algorithm which is
uh slightly different than this one and
just by a little bit
you can get uh
uh kind of if
q
[Music]
star lowering
so without the condition on the low rate
conditions you can get a sample
complexities
uh if you can get a sample complexity of
this
h to the sixth
which
i mean we were very happy with that it
should be six but at least
at least style
uh
at least it doesn't blow up
um
and the second thing we show zach
if q star is low rank
um plus
min gap
founded
away from zero by delta
then we can get a
downhill complexity that looks like
h4
um
but this algorithm is also really weird
and so it's not something i'm really
happy with either
um
and i'll tell you i guess i'll tell you
a little bit
the h26 doesn't bother me that much if
you can get the r times s plus a
yeah so we can get it
uh a little bit of conditions like
yes
you still need those conditions okay
um okay yeah i mean we uh i don't know
how to get around this condition um
[Music]
i don't know how to get around this
condition
[Music]
estimation
but then we're allowing ourselves a
generative model
like if
we did if we were allowed to do actually
something
like one matrix estimation and we can
find even just one sparse we can find
that entry it's not
just i mean i understand here that
transitions like you are interacting
but
yeah the necessity of incoherence isn't
that clear when you make the analogy to
make the destination because
uh you're right you're right um
but the tricky thing i think is that uh
suppose you had active sampling
and you
knew where the signal was
then you're good and in particular
that is a result in the classic matrix
estimation literature is that you can
get rid of in coherence
but you have to by having a sampling
pattern
which where the sampling probabilities
are constructed as a function of the
coherence parameters it's kind of really
weird i mean right which is cheating
kind of i don't know i'm saying even
more than that i'm saying
the sampling pattern is constructed as
you observe
oh
one
of the left
values one of the right places at a time
and then find the max effectiveness game
but i mean if you but if you had like a
really bad setting where it was like
totally sparse like this like one and
zero is everywhere then you would still
be
like you still have you'd have to hit
that point right
so if it's really really sparse
and you're trying to find this one point
you're still kind of
in trouble
so there needs to be i mean i think low
rank itself can't be enough of a factor
it needs to be lowering plus something
but i don't know what does something
like what would be a reasonable
something like i agree
this is not like
the the fact that this corner may just
seem to be all right that doesn't seem
to be the right
kind of sort of assumption because
that's
so the end prepared scores for the
sparse example is just going to tell you
to sample in that one spot
right well yeah yeah
exactly so it's kind of silly right so
if i knew this incoherent scores it
would tell me where the signal is that i
just sampled right yeah but that's like
that's cheating because we don't know
where this is right
um
so uh
is there a sense that you can say if you
don't know where
i think that there is
there should be something that we can
like we should be able to rely on
something here so they when they come
banned it we had some universe that you
can
push through
it's very special i don't know how to
generalize yeah exactly that problem
it's like searching for this
for the peak it's kind of like a
random sub-sampling of frozen columns
and then some elimination
targeting
but then you're going to get stuck with
the scenic though
no because like
so what happens
is that you see all these zeroes
and from that you know that okay like
the corresponding muchness sort of have
to be zeros
and then you're not something there
anymore
so you're gonna sample somewhere else
that's what i thought so i mean are you
saying you could get are you saying this
yeah yeah that's what i thought you can
you can
active
and then based on something in the
middle you
making francis on the marching and
that's enough to eliminate enough
push the probability mass out of the bad
parts
because you're only searching for the
maximum of this unimodal function
that's not the same as estimating all
the matrix
we're just trying to find the needle
but it's unimoda so it's like it's it's
a nice structure
it's like this one-dimensional case
i don't know how to do it maybe that's
something that's like is this is there
like when you say it's not incoherent is
there like some special structure that
you might expect
yeah i also wonder if something can be
like even
uh like if there could be some
relaxed notion of like local
like it's
like you only care about the regions of
the state space that you visit or that
you can't you know
so we don't need to
how do we prove a lot about we shouldn't
rule out
it's possible to do it
but i do i will rush with these extra
conditions
yeah
just have to
yeah think some more i i would
definitely be super curious of uh
getting a little vacuum too
i'm not sure what that would look like
have you got empirical
examples like what does the structure of
the queue matrix look like yeah so this
group um
child elsewhere actually have done some
examples and they have actually shown
uh empirical like positive results in
their virtual
um we work for they have done uh like
matrix estimation with plus ro for our
artillery game and
looked at like some of them are actually
are the way
um
they had looked at some simple control
problems and they did the pendulum one
there are some problems that definitely
act well i would
yeah maybe even the transition is long
right not just the q star like the the
examples actually
so their empirical results actually
think about that
this cue style realizability
is hard a lot of kids when things are
just linear
and here there are many more unknowns
i don't know whether
so for example if if five was known
and psi is unknown
that's gonna be a hopeless case i think
how does it work
so if phi is known oh and psi is unknown
then that's just a linear case
which is if you have linearly
parameterized q star
it's a very it's it's okay so the basis
functions have some extra structure
so you have to reason about that the
hardness example still goes through uh
it's hard no i think the hardness
examples for linearity oh i see you
you're saying
but here you're allowing us
huh here you're allowing guest
defendants
yeah sure i mean sure
if if you want to learn both phi and psi
you should download s and independence
for sure but if i say that phi is given
to you then the s dependence should be
gone
and if that would be hard
then uh
yeah the whole problem is gonna be hard
if yeah
let's think about that
you can have some
something that might be more reasonable
to replace something replace this
or something that's more motivating
that's probably
[Music]
that you get
an excellent optimal policy but but it's
i think it's with the
uh
for every for every
like you get a your your estimate for
the hat
minus the baby star of us
you get the same results for relaxed
conditions too so
things do not get easier if you have a
fixed initial state
so what kind of a structural assumption
do you need to ensure the
killstar is slower so that's the same
reward and transition of both flora
that's identified oh that's sufficient
yeah
if transitions are rewarding
um
but i know uh how to solve two lower
rewards laurent matrix
uh i mean it would be that you would
have like a sum of a rank r plus another
car would be um
bounded by 2r oh yeah
another question is regarding on the
symbol complexity
why is there an s instead of the size of
the uncured states
um
because so uh
you are still
like for the special set of anger states
you're sampling all the actions but for
every state you have sampling
but you still have a you're still incur
then you're in this are you
oh
i mean
you
can't hear because
uh the anchor sits are just like the set
of states that
kind of span the rose space but you
still need to learn for the other states
so for the other states i need to learn
like
how how is this state related to the set
of existence
so for the set of integer states you
have seven different states times a but
for the other states you just have a set
of anchors that all states have only
those
actions so what you're gaining is that
you're not saying you need to
have a multiplicative
uh cost between
it's related to the the flambe paper
by
so they see how they're just trying to
learn the representation but they assume
there are just a finite number of uh
uh possibilities of the feature mapping
oh
the
sorry see it see
that the name is slander
a m
[Music]
we're solving
for emily and uh
i think that's not the problem
that's that's fine
we don't care that much
about competition
but i think that the long
cardiology might kill you because you
might need to animate too many of these
maps to have some cover
and then the s times say
a
yeah but then if you have like smooth
feature or some structure on the feature
then the carbon number might be smaller
than
yeah
that's additional assumptions
down here yeah
i'm sure i can see why
looking at the coverage of probably
one minute
do they take the product up the two
spaces and take the log of the parameter
of that space and
and that is going to scavenge s times
say
because once guess
this as the other sketches hey take the
product you're
you're doomed that's
it's a true cool set of problems
happy to hear
think he gave us a lot of forward
hey
let's see
what do you think
so
oh